in just a few short weeks CCSD students
are going to head back to class and now
is really the time to prep your kids
really focus on their mental health
there's a free resource available for
parents covering a variety of topics
it's kind of on demand if you will
joining me now to discuss family mental
health and wellness nights Mark welling
with parent guidance thank you so much
for being here oh we're so excited to be
here and be talking to parents in Clark
County about this wonderful resource
this is a free resource for parents a
big partnership for you to include CCSD
which is a huge school district oh it
really is amazing to see what CCSD is
doing for their families and this
partnership and so part of this parents
will have available to them we have a
mental health series and so we've
partnered with CCSD to be able to
provide topics that they have hand
selected they go to their school
counselors and school psychologists and
see topics that parents could really
benefit from so there's anything from
how to help their children with anxiety
how to set proper boundaries with social
media about have better communication in
the home and so really what they found
is on and CCSD really understands this
eighty percent of parents know that they
seek Mental Health Resources from the
school system and so to be able to go
there and have meaningful resources and
be able to have guides that they can go
to and be that caring adult in the home
really it's such a protective Factor
when it comes to mental health and
well-being of families and sometimes you
don't see it for your own children and
it isn't until you start going through
some things that you realize it's so
important to have those resources
available to you oh yeah and in addition
to the mental health series one of the
other really cool things that we've
worked with CCSD and other partners
Nationwide is parent coaching this is
one where parents can sign up at no cost
and it's available in both English and
Spanish they are paired with an
individual coach where they were able to
have weekly sessions where they're able
to go in talk about any needs or
concerns they might have as parents and
really have that National support and
additionally they're available 24 7 so
if they have a concern or something
comes up during the week and that
confidence they're able to text email
and they get a response within 24 hours
and so that extra confidence and ability
for the parent to know what they should
do in that moment really is empowering
and helpful in that situation and it
doesn't make you a bad parent you know
it makes you a good parent to be able to
reach out and ask for help and I imagine
the anonymity of being able to do this
virtually also assists because there
still is a stigma oh yes the stigma
really does exist and being able to talk
about it and be able to go through and
really see the ability that all of us
need help like as parents we all know we
want to do what's the very best for kids
and take the village it really does and
with and the scary thing is with all the
CDC data that's been coming out and with
all the the trends of teams that are
feeling persistently sad uh that are
thinking about suicide ideation and it
really does scare parents and they feel
like they're failing and as talking to
parents in Clark County over the past
few weeks it's been really amazing to
see the love and concern they have for
their kids they want to do what's very
best for them and all of us can use that
little bit of help I use it all the time
just to better communicate with my
daughters sure and make sure that I'm
doing the right thing there is no bad
thing to be want to be a better parent
I'm working
prop for us all I think well if you'd
like more information or to sign up for
these parent courses go to
parentguidance.org and the courses are
available in both English and Spanish
for free